we had a few key words right trust
science all those words science by the
way it was very
interesting listening to uh michael give
his perspective on trump
uh as a small business owner his life
and the people around his life got
better because of
president trump so that's an interesting
take but here's the key words here's the
key words that i wrote down
on the differences between the two one
was
democrats blame america for everything
okay
dnc talked about how much they despise
america
this was about dreams okay this was
about dreams dnc was about nightmare
this is all about dreams everything was
dreams dreams dreams dreams dreams
and it was different on the other side
i'll go down the aisle with every one of
them i have
uh 16 17 speakers so i'll just give you
the main highlights jim jordan talked
about
the democrats want to defund police
defund border patrol defund the military
we won't let you go to church
but we'll let you protest we won't let
you go to work but we'll let you riot
it's kind of interesting then he told
the story about his nephew eli
who died a few years uh last year i
believe
and the father's name of eli is todd and
trump calls jim jordan say how you doing
he says how's the family doing so we're
not doing too well
then jim jordan asked would you be
willing to talk to the father for a few
minutes
trump got on the phone and talked to
todd for five minutes and the family was
sitting there just to mourn together the
loss of a
child you know this kid was a prodigy
coming up with a wrestler
so jim talked about the connection side
of what he did on the family side i
thought it was powerful message
that he gave the couple pointed guns at
the blm protesters in saint louis they
spoke
and i don't know if you saw that talk or
not they just got up and they said look
you know none of us uh are looting
outside the house we're charred none of
us it says
none of the looters were charged with a
crime but we were so let me get this
straight people are coming to my house
my private property and i'm the one
that's charged with a crime and they're
not how does that make any sense so
they're protecting the looters but
they're not protecting
their citizens they talk about
pro-second amendment
we're not the kind of people that back
down neither is donald trump donald
trump brought us the best economy ever
but the democrats have brought
at us brought us nothing but
distractions so that was them
good talk safe good talk that they gave
vernon jones i thought
crushed it uh he's the guy who were
talking about the georgia democrat state
representative
he said black people are free with free
minds so he didn't like the fact that
democrats said i cannot believe you're
going to speak at the end at the rnc and
you know he says i got letters i got
threats they told me to resign all this
he says that's the thing with the black
mob
they do this just because i am rep
supporting a
president that's doing good for them he
says here's joe biden who talks about
he's going to make change he says you've
been in office for 47 years
trump's been in office for three years
you've been in office for 47 years you
had a chance to make results you have no
results
it's all talk no action great point 47
years
uh that was interesting he says if i
work hard this is he says my dad told me
hey son if you work hard treat people
fairly
there's nothing you couldn't accomplish
in your life again dreams
dreams that's the messaging right he
says trump did a
historical criminal uh justice reform
what he did uh
he spoke about police officers and he
says well you know that's so that's
vernon jones i thought it was a good
talk nikki haley
she came out and she told a story about
ambassador jean kirkpatrick
that in 1984 he gave this talk this
ambassador because she was also an
ambassador
uh nikki haley u.n right she said she
said that this ambassador
during reagan in 1984 says democrats
always
blame america first democrats always
blame america first
that's her point in the first 30 seconds
by the way when she came out there was a
couple guys that made points like that
her matt gates was right off the bat
so she made that point then she said joe
has a record of weakness and failure joe
biden is good for iran and isis great
for communist china and godsent for
anyone who wants to
who wants america america to apologize
abstain abandon our values let me say
this one more time what you said
it's a powerful line joe biden is has a
record of weakness and failure he's good
for iran and isis
great for communist china and god sent
for anyone who wants america to
apologize abstain and abandon our values
okay that's a
very strong statement shitaba cutting
taxes
we cut taxes they raised them in her
state uh
when we brought good jobs to south
carolina obama obama and biden sued her
her state
they want to tell americans how to think
americans know how to think
democrats love telling everyone that
america is a racist nation america's not
a racist nation
um then they she talked about cops cops
matter black cops matter black cops
lives matter
black small business owners lives matter
and then she went on this part with
uh progress which i thought again she
crushes she gave a very good message
it's a kind of a message that maybe four
eight years from now people are going to
look at and says
what's the bench look like you know when
when obama gave that talk and all four
they're like listen that's a good bench
we have a guy that we can do something
around and oh wait
she's kind of getting into that league
she's both
not liked by some republicans and not
liked by some democrats which could be a
good thing when she runs because that's
kind of like
what trump had going on she's got a
similar trump card
in a different way that could work for
matt gates came out the gates firing
he said first sentence i'm speaking to
you in an auditorium
emptier than joe biden's schedule it's
his opening line
i'm speaking to you in an auditorium
emptier than joe biden's schedule
pretty strong opening when you say
settle for biden is a hashtag promoted
by aocn socialist let me say this one
more time
aoc and the socialists have a hashtag
that's being used on twitter i don't
even know if you know about it
it's called settle for biden settle
for biden meaning let's just settle for
biden forget about trump let's get this
guy out
but don't get it twisted aoc and the
socialists do not want
bite them you saw who she endures the
left wing wants to make america weaker
to move their agenda forward so that was
his message andrew pollock
school safety activist gunman shot his
daughter five times and she died on
february 14 2018. this is a guy
with a lot of swagger a lot of
confidence and heartfelt you feel this
guy
and after his daughter's murder i
noticed the media wasn't interested in
the fact
so they didn't tell her story but they
told other stories
his daughter innocent daughter in school
gets her can you imagine your kid is
dice gets shot five times just because
what does she do she did
nothing so he told that story very
powerful
far left democrats made the shooting in
the school possible that's andrew
pollock
donald trump jr i mean he he was
interesting to me
um the one thing that he did say that
was powerful he said the chinese
communist party prefers biden
okay which he's right he sold the dream
it was constant dream america is about
imagine he used the word imagine i think
10 times imagine a world where you can
live your dreams you can have that
you can have he kept saying this you can
have that i thought he did a good job
kimberly was a little bit uncomfortable
watching her
especially if you watch her on 2.0 speed
on youtube it was very difficult
watching her
uh it was it almost seemed like there's
a video of them
of donald trump jr drinking two red
bulls before the talk
okay on instagram he posted on his dad
shared it it looked like
she had one too many red bulls when she
gave the talk
she talked about human sex trafficking
and uh you know in president
trump's america we like things up is
what she said
in president trump's america we like
things up the market
you have to watch it okay the the the
church market all this other stuff you
know could be
taken out of context herschel walker
said what he said uh
ronald mcdonald rnc chair she said i'm
the second woman 164 years to run the
rnc
and he didn't choose me because i'm a
woman he chose me because i'm qualified
to do this job second woman which is
pretty interesting that everybody says
trump doesn't support women yet the rnc
chair is a
woman it's kind of by the way somebody
called that trump the other day and says
yes
the rnc chairman is a woman and they
were shocked most people didn't even
know this
that that is the case does trump choose
the head of the rnc yes the president
chooses the head of the rnc
did so the support has to come from
there kim klasik
baltimore this this girl's fireball
young candidate baltimore's video went
viral
she crushed it again democrats assumed
that black girl black people will
constantly work for them blindly
she says we want safety in our
neighborhood lower taxes better
education better jobs and i think she's
got a good career ahead of her
maximum oliver did a great job when you
know he escaped fidel castro and
communist regime to come over here i
thought he did a fantastic job
tim scott talked about education 7
million jobs pre-coveted
two-thirds of the jobs that trump
created out of the seven million went to
women latinos and african-american
that's just record-breaking on what he
did charlie kirk gave a good job
uh trump got up there and he talked
about the 80 million ballots right off
the bat
in the first 30 seconds what he talked
about is the ballads
his post office first thing he talked
about was that
it wasn't like he took 20 minutes you
have to know that when you're giving a
speech
you got to know your first minute's
going to be remembered whatever you say
in the minute that's what everyone's
going to watch not a minute 51 not
minute 48
minute one he talked about 80 million
ballots and they're working post office
scandals as i'm preparing all of you
they're already talking about it because
they're talking about it's their
strategy it is a scandal
he called it the most important election
in the history of our country
he said success brings people together
he says pre-covet while everybody was
making money
401ks was good democrats were very happy
with me because success brings people
together
now because of cove things have divided
so look at your 401k you should look at
your 401k
because it's doing good because the
market's back up nasdaq has broken the
record 16 times now
farmers he got them 28 billion from
china november 4th everything's going
back to normal biden's comment i'd shut
down the economy if
kind of took a shot there and then he
talked about vaccines stage
3 trials it's you know most people
wouldn't predict that go this far
until a few minutes ago nobody knew it
was coming last minute he decided to
come and talk because of what that state
did he campaigned there before
he called msnbc the usual msdnc the nc
took
under god out of the national anthem on
to their meetings that they had when
they did the
not the national anthem the pledge of
allegiance they took under god out it
was during two meetings it was the lgbtq
caucus meeting and the muslim delegates
assembly didn't say
under god and then they're trying to
steal the election you know rigged
election bernie sanders is the greatest
loser i've ever met
this guy's so happy you just lost what
are you happy about
bernie sanders the greatest loser ever
he says
you lost your chance to be a president
why are you smiling
china had its worst year in 67 years
which is what's happened to their
economy we now have it that the
signature doesn't have to be verified
signature doesn't have to be verified to
vote it's kind of weird
we build their wall it'll be done
shortly and he talked about some of his
accomplishments
how many judges they chose cut drug
prices first time in 51 years
can you imagine 51 years first time they
cut drug prices anyways
so that's the message he gave okay with
the the speakers that spoke there
it was the first night to me was
watching it
you were kind of like here's here's
here's the best example i'll give you
i don't like to go to church here's why
i don't like to go to church
you'd go to church and there was pastors
who would get up
to collect money and this happens
sometimes in the art there's a big
armenian church that
had a big fallen out and a lot of people
that had money
left this church and a lot of them quite
frankly stepped away from the
religion of christianity because of the
way that church handled things
my friend was a hardcore christian he
converted me and he stepped away okay
and you know what it had to do with
money
but here's one of the things on how
church uses the bible
there's two ways they convert people one
of them they get
get up and the pastor says what the
pastor says if
you don't give your life to christ
you're going to hell
here's what hell looks like you ever
seen these advertisements they paint
what hell looks like with volcanoes and
fire and you're going to be burning up
in hell oh yeah
and then there's the other pastor that
gets up and says listen man you can go
to heaven
let me tell you what heaven looks like
you're gonna see your family
maybe you've been away from your grandma
or your mom or your husband you're gonna
see them again
this is heaven so they're both trying to
get people to convert
to go to heaven one is selling hell the
other one is selling heaven
dnc was selling hell rnc was selling
heaven very big difference in
perspective and the biggest churches in
the world
they tend to sell heaven